hey what's going on it's bill burns it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
i'm not checking in on you
today's the monday morning podcast
that's what it is
oh jesus christ anyway i'm on vacation
here i'm not really on vacation because
i have the biggest gig of my [ __ ]
life in six days
six
five four three it's just sitting here
with the damn thing like just hanging
over my head i just want to go do the
[ __ ] show
jesus christ
it's so funny too it's like the last day
of my vacation so the whole my whole
vacation i can't [ __ ] relax because i
got this giant gig
um
just [ __ ] sitting there i feel like
you know like in between like the afc
championship game in the super bowl when
they would used to have like a two-week
break i don't they still have that they
go back and forth
you have that one sunday where you just
don't play that's what i feel like right
now
or it's just like i know it's gonna go
great but i'm sick i'm sick of like
[ __ ] waiting
to do it let's just [ __ ]
let's just do it
you know so
i think i've been a little on edge here
even though i've been having a great
time
i bought a patriots fitted hat
um
the other day
and like it just quickly escalated
into the fact of like you know if i say
one more thing i'm actually gonna have
to fight this guy
and he was like six five three hundred
pounds it could have swallowed me like a
[ __ ] komodo dragon so once again i
just had to like not say anything
because i'm 5 10 180 54 [ __ ] years
old
you know
it just started off so innocently i was
like hey do you have this hat and seven
and three eights you just have seven and
a quarter and he came walking over and
he starts sifting through and he hands
me a hat
and it was seven and a quarter i said no
i said seven and three eighths
and the guy was just like uh he goes no
you didn't
i go yes i did he goes no you didn't i
said i said seven and three eights and
he goes i know what you said
you said seven and a quarter
and then it just [ __ ] escalated to
this ridiculous [ __ ] level and i just
had to sit there and just be like all
right
he's way bigger than me he can beat the
[ __ ] out of me and i just have to
[ __ ] take this right and then i i
like for half a second i was like ugh
i'm not gonna buy the hat like he gives
a [ __ ]
you know
and then what then this guy's a douche
and then i also don't get the hat i want
no [ __ ] that i'm gonna get the hat
and then i just walked out and i was so
[ __ ] pissed
like the the way i got past my anger
was
thinking to myself like that guy's not
going to be alive in 10 years
at the height he is and the weight he is
because he wasn't muscular he was fat
but you could see he used to maybe be
play some sports even he [ __ ] blocked
for emmett smith
so i was just like you know what he'll
be dead in 10 years
okay
so if you're ever wondering what it was
like to uh be in boston and experience
the atmosphere that's what it's like
being in boston is is going in and just
trying to buy a [ __ ] hat of the local
sports team
and some little [ __ ] confusion about
the [ __ ] size you're now hoping that
the person who sold you the [ __ ] hat
actually began the sale and then just
sort of [ __ ] walked off and let
somebody else handle it you're hoping
that that guy's gonna be dead in ten
years
like that's the thing that is so you can
go get on with your day and not take it
out on other [ __ ] people
it's unfucking believable
i just wish i had the ability when he
said you said seven and a quarter i sh
even though i knew he was [ __ ] wrong
i should have just been like oh i'm so
oh my mistake oh did i i'm sorry
i'm sorry about that
my mistake
i guess i don't know you know i guess i
don't know a meal
sorry my kids are downstairs i said what
my [ __ ] hat size is i guess i don't
know what that is
and i guess you do you fat [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was a food order he
would have heard it
you know i swear to god dude and
everybody has this [ __ ] story do you
know when i was driving up here
no i'm driving up here i was going to
the airport the guy driving me to the
airport was a yankee fan he told me 30
years ago he came up here because he
always wanted to see fenway park since
he was a kid he had respect for the park
he comes up here he's puerto rican he's
got new york plates somebody calls him a
racial slur and next thing you know you
know what he did when he went to fenway
he didn't go in
he didn't go to the game he walked up to
the park and he took a piss on it and
[ __ ] drove back to new york
that's what this place is
that's what it's always been and i'm
just hoping these younger kids
who are all claiming that they're woke
are truly woke and they'll finally turn
this place around because it is such a
great place and i do love it but when i
come back here and i just try to buy a
[ __ ] hat and i get so mad i'm wishing
or an early death
on the person that started to sell me
the hat and then just tapped out because
of his own [ __ ] childhood issues
i think to myself you know what it's
kind of great that my kids aren't going
to grow up with this
we'll just visit once a year we'll come
in we'll get some [ __ ] clams
we'll go to a couple of games we'll
drive around we'll have some bar pizza
we'll visit the
the relatives and then we'll just get
out of here
and we'll go back to [ __ ] la which is
completely racist in in an entirely
different way
um it is amazing though how how much
people don't understand los angeles
at all and they just think it's all like
oh everybody out there so [ __ ]
plastic and blah blah blah blah blah
it's like
as far as la goes like hollywood is like
the size of like a postage stamp
and the rest of it is a bunch of [ __ ]
lunatics
you know gun owners
[ __ ]
racist
[ __ ] lunatics
um
and i'm not saying gun owners are racist
i'm just saying they think it's all
[ __ ] hippy dippy out there it is in
hollywood it is
the second you get outside of that
forget it
forget it it will give it'll give any
conservative [ __ ] city a run for its
money
um
but that's not what people [ __ ] think
of um anyway
so uh
yeah um
so i spent a couple days
um
here
as you can tell i'm [ __ ] on edge here
i just really just want to do this
[ __ ] show i just want to do the show
just do the [ __ ] show all right
instead of like tick tock tick tock tick
tock
um
but in the meantime i've been having a
great time
you know we found this great coffee shop
that has an absolutely incredible
espresso up here
and had amazing pastries and breakfast
you know they have like [ __ ] on the
weekend they have like uh
uh lamb hash or whatever i didn't try
because i'm trying not to be a fat [ __ ]
for this gig
but um you know really nice place like
one of those food network kind of places
you know
so we're standing there it was like
saturday so you know it was a little bit
of a line
and it was moving or whatever but you
know
since this couple behind us
and the woman says to the boyfriend was
just like oh man it's kind of a line
here
you want to go someplace else what do
you think
you want to go go someplace else and
he's like yeah
this place is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
it's like
it's not a [ __ ] show they're not [ __ ]
up the orders nobody's screaming and
yelling there's just a line
that that like that alone
makes it a [ __ ] show it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show
a [ __ ] show
it's too crowded
i don't want to wait i get that but it's
not a [ __ ] show
it was a very
well-run [ __ ] restaurant and you
didn't want to wait for eight people to
order whatever the [ __ ] it is that you
want to [ __ ] order so now dude it's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] show dude the post office
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
all right going to the mall
over christmas is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
that's a [ __ ] show
standing in line with eight people in
front of you with [ __ ] every option
you could possibly ever want for
breakfast
i mean dude they had it all
avocado toast
[ __ ] french toast all the [ __ ]
toasts
any [ __ ] pancake you want i mean you
it was [ __ ] eden is where the hell
you were this guy it was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show
um
anyway
um
none of this has to do with anything
other than the fact
that i just want to [ __ ]
you know
i just want to do this [ __ ] show like
on on
uh saturday i took my daughter to her
first game
and uh when i went into fenway that's
you know
actually one point i was you know
because i was obviously taking in the
fact that i was taking my kid to her
first game which was so important it had
to be at fenway had to be the red sox i
wasn't going to make the mistake that my
west coast friends make where they go to
a [ __ ] red sox game on the west coast
they go to like red sox versus the
angels
and then like the angels mascot comes up
to the kid and [ __ ] tosses them on
the head and then that's it now the
kid's a [ __ ] angels fan
not doing that i had to take her to
fenway we had to take the green line had
to get off at kenmore square walk up the
hill go over mass pike listen to the
scalpers
all of that [ __ ]
and go in
you know
walk past where that poor guy who got
called the bad word the [ __ ] racial
slur pissed on the park
um
and went in and we ended up having uh we
had a great time
and my daughter was totally in it you
know into its uh wally
the mascot or whatever which i've never
been a fan of but now that she waved
he waved or whatever
you know up to where we were sitting my
daughter was convinced that he was
waving at her
by the second inning she said to me she
goes hey dad what do you think about
this
what if i said this and i said what and
she goes red sox win yankees lose red
sox win yankees lose and i was just like
that's right buddy that's [ __ ] great
i didn't say [ __ ] it but i'm like that's
great
so
i got her on board hopefully
um
but we just had like the best time my
daughter's big thing was she wanted to
eat cracker jacks
because of the uh take me out to the
ball game song
so i got a great picture of her cute
little hands opening up their first
package of cracker jacks
um
what else we took the train over there
we got some great pictures
um
but you know it was also like her uh you
know
her bedtime you know so by the third
inning
she was zonked out so we only you know
she's only five we made three innings
and then we went down to the pro shop
across the street
i got a hat and she got herself
something
and then we cruised back there was a cab
sitting out there we jumped in
we went back to our hotel and uh
it was just like the perfect day because
earlier that day i'd gone by the
hardware store
and i bought a wiffle ball in bat and i
was pitching to my uh my daughter
right in the boston commons
she was [ __ ] hit you know getting a
lot of hits i was so proud of her and
then my son wanted to go up and hit
and because my daughter's a lefty he
started swinging lefty too so i think
they're both going to throw right and
bat left which i think is pretty cool
and um
[Music]
you know i was hanging in the park but
just the two of them
and my wife
and then they have the uh make way for
ducklings we rode on the swan boats
yeah it was just
it was just like the perfect day it was
like
72 degrees out
like both days like the whole thing was
perfect which was so funny
to be in the middle of that paradise and
hear that guy going oh dude it's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] show
well my son's on one today
all right i'm gonna have to [ __ ] wrap
this podcast up soon
um
anyway well jesus only done 13 minutes
what am i talking about here
so anyway uh
yeah so i'm back up here i actually did
a spot at nick's comedy stop
uh i got to work with the great mike
donovan
one of my favorite boston stand-up
comics
and somebody that i learned so much
from when i would open for him way back
in the day
um
particularly uh
his use of the microphone
and he was really cognizant of when he
was being loud and taking the microphone
away and he had all these different
little
subtle tricks that would add to what it
was that he was doing on stage and he
used to do this great um
impression
of the local uh
play-by-play announcer for the uh boston
celtics the late great johnny most
and uh he's almost hold like the
microphone sideways and cup his hand
over it and would just do like this dead
on johnny most
uh impression but anyway he was um
he was headlining so i went down and i
opened for him
um at the place where i started 30 years
before
and uh same goddamn place
they've redone it a little bit but it's
just still the same place
and every time i walk in there i expect
to see the late great bobby flank hey
kid shut that [ __ ] door that's what
he always say hey bear bill shut that
[ __ ] door do me a favor shut that
[ __ ] door
that was like his catch catchphrase shut
that [ __ ] door
and then when you go up the stairs
and you make like the two turns
and as i come up there i always expect
to see the late great kevin knox
standing there looking at the lineup
with the pen in his hand and the piece
of paper
you know in his [ __ ]
braveheart level mullet that he had
and then walking in and looking to the
left
and see in those four red chairs that
would have like patrice dane
bobby kelly
someone else every time i i have that
exact
memory
and um
yeah but i go in there and obviously
nobody's there
which is weird but then i go on stage
and it's still the same the same room so
i went up
i had a good time i
tried out some of the boston stories
that i uh
yeah i might tell at the fenway gig
if that gig ever happens
um i still can't believe i'm gonna do
stand up there it's gonna be [ __ ]
amazing and i'm i just i'm chomping at
the bit here people i could literally i
swear to god
i could just there's a dresser here i
could just [ __ ]
gnaw off one of the goddamn handles here
i'm just like let's [ __ ] go
um
anyway i don't i gotta i gotta be
careful with that energy because my
wife's gonna be like what's going on
with you come on we're on vacation
but she's right
she's right so
um
i threw my back out walking up some
stairs
walking up government center
coming back from the north end
um
i went over there
i uh
smoked a cigar
it's whatever i never can remember the
name of that because it's such a crazy
[ __ ] name
is it stanza what the hell's the name of
the place i'm gonna get it i'm gonna get
it done right now
all right hang on a second
cigar bar
north end
stanza
d sagari
that's what it is
i went down there
smoked a cigar
and just shot the [ __ ] with some [ __ ]
hilarious people this italian chick from
austin texas
who didn't know how to cook which i
thought was hilarious
my cod is an italian end up in
texas and she was talking about how her
dad got transferred down there or
something like that
and like you don't know how to cook
she's like no she's like my dad can cook
i'm like he never taught you he's like
now
like all right what part of texas i go i
love texas what part of texas are you in
she's like austin i went ugh
[Laughter]
she goes why she goes what part of texas
do you like i go dallas she goes dallas
she goes it's all just
[ __ ]
phony and fake and blah blah i go that's
what i love about dallas
there's an honesty
you know
they're just trying to [ __ ]
we're in texas everything's bigger here
look how big my [ __ ] bed is right
there's just something funny about that
as opposed to [ __ ] austin texas was a
bunch of white people pretending they're
they have money problems
um
anyways just tease i don't know [ __ ]
about texas but
um
just ended up you know it's just an
afternoon crowd and then i got my place
where i go to get my sandwiches
um
and there's a bakery right next door to
it it's not on that main drag whatever
that
street name is that they've turned into
a one-way street for whatever [ __ ]
reason
they just turned it into like a one-way
street they just and they didn't make it
a two-way one-way they just shut down
the other lane
i don't know who comes up with that [ __ ]
it's like it's totally congested let's
just make it impossible now
and then they always think that people
are going to choose public
transportation and they just don't it's
like that stupid [ __ ] hov lane nobody
uses it
it's motorcycles and a couple of [ __ ]
old ladies on the way to some lunchtime
special and everybody else is just
jammed up in this other lane no one has
ever been like hey you know what
i think i'm gonna start going to [ __ ]
work with my friend nobody does it
uh nobody bill i don't know not enough
so i was coming back
from uh
from the north end walking back over to
my hotel and i was going up the stairs
at government center
and i ended up throwing out my back
it's finally better after like two
days i'll tell you what's stupid is when
you throw at your back and somebody
wants to give you a leave or tylenol
and it's like what so it can mask the
symptoms that i actually threw out my
back and i can [ __ ] up my liver in the
process or i can sit here and stretch
and work it out hey work it out okay
baby all right um
so
anyway um that was kind of my trip out
here to uh
massachusetts so far i'm gonna hang with
the family
you know
have a good time and all that type of
stuff then i'm gonna
try to run out and do spots here or
there so my ax stays tight oh look who
it is
the lovely nia
hey how fun i was joking about that guy
oh this place is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
um
what are you doing today nothing
nothing all right absolutely nothing
a lot of nothing
all right
what an
[ __ ]
um a lot of nothing just like your act
in case you missed that in case she was
too far away um oh i did watch the end
of a great movie last night that i had
never seen
uh that my wife was telling me how much
she loved the movie it was to die for
starring nicole kidman and joaquin
phoenix
it was loosely based
on the pamela smart case
where she was a 22 year old banging a 15
year old
and she convinced him
to kill her 24 year old husband
because she didn't want to get divorced
and lose
some money and then she also had life
insurance on him
one of the more [ __ ] up
stories i remember growing up
it was a lot of [ __ ] up cases
there was the other one where the white
guy tried to blame the black guy
you 5-0 you 5-0 that one
the [ __ ] was his name jumped off the
mystic tobin bridge
um
and they arrested like every black guy
in the [ __ ] city or harassed him or
whatever and then it turned out that it
was the white dude and he killed his
wife
spoiler alert
what the [ __ ] was that one called i
can't remember that one either but
anyways we watched that movie and it was
done um
just the way it was shot the whole thing
was [ __ ] amazing just dude joaquin
phoenix he's just the guy's always been
a great actor
he was already a great actor and he was
like a teenager when he did that one
obviously he's playing a teen and nicole
kidman i think that that was like one of
some of the best work i saw her do
and i never
i didn't remember when that movie came
out i think it came out like 95 when i
looked it up and that's just when i
written as i moved down to new york
so i was so focused on
you know getting stand-up gigs and not
going broke so i could actually pay my
rent
that i missed out on uh
a lot of [ __ ]
like i know everybody's excited that
they're gonna make another heat i don't
think i really ever saw the first one
um
i know i think i saw it in the movie
theater but
yeah i can't remember
that whole part of my life
when i first moved to new york in 95
until about 2003 is just a blur of like
scratching and clawing and trying to get
gigs
so i wouldn't end up you know [ __ ]
homeless
i know the yankees won a bunch of world
series then
i knew sports the red wings won a couple
the sabres got [ __ ]
on that in the crease call i remember
that
anyway let me do some uh let me do some
reads here
for the week all right what do we got
here
who is it oh
oh look who it is everybody it's all zip
rack crude
you know there are so many more things
to do during the summer and you want to
free up as much time as possible to
enjoy them so if you're a business owner
the last thing you want to do is sort
through tons of unqualified candidates
resumes
when you could be
when you could be dot dot dot
i don't know what
just getting right to the best client
and going out and playing badminton in
your bermuda shorts uh that's why you
need zip recruiter to find great
candidates they do the work for you and
now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
ziprecruiter uses its powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job you can
easily review easily
review these recommended candidates and
invite your top choices to apply
additionally zip
rick
has a complete suite of tools
that makes it easy to filter review and
rate your candidates four to five
employers who use it yes
get a quality candidate within the first
day within the first day no wonder zip
recruiter is the number one rated hiring
site based on g2 satisfaction ratings as
of january first twenty twenty two so
soak up all that summer has to offer and
let zip
do the work
ready for the url it's ziprecruiter.com
that's where you can try it for free
again that's ziprecruiter
z-i-p-r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r
dot-com
b-u-r-r zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
all right
and with that ah jesus what did i just
do here
let's get into some of the questions
some of the questions for the day
hey
uh won't you play another
somebody ask me a [ __ ] question
um
by the way
what are the odds i wanna see what the
odds are
for the yankees to win the world series
you know because now i'm getting faster
i'm getting fascinated with this [ __ ]
because it looked like they were going
to run away with it let's look at the
[ __ ] stats here and this is all i
have right now and all you yankee fans
just know
that i am hating because i i got nothing
left
mlb standings
all right
we're finished for the year
yankees 72 and 43. last 10 though two
and eight
[ __ ] blue jays three and seven can
you make a [ __ ] move they're ten
games out
the devil rays are 11 games out the
orioles at 12 and a half oh look who's
in the cellar
the boston red sox
that's actually a good division i mean
the fact that we're in last place were
only two games under 500 that's not bad
um
yeah look at these other [ __ ]
divisions they got people 371 414 357
443 447.
you know that those are some weak
divisions all right then you got the
houston astros
um they're 75 and 41.
and the cleveland guardians
61 and 53.
so the astros have the best record in
the american league followed by the
yankees now wait a second now wait wait
just one goddamn moment here
yeah so the [ __ ] blue jays
they added some player i don't know who
they're they're in the lead for the wild
card and
it would be them versus the mariners ah
i think the uh i guess the astros would
be their biggest [ __ ] problem
you know but they kind of get caught now
so i mean what are they gonna do
the astros that is
they can't bring out the [ __ ]
the cameras and the trash cans again um
the mets
75 and 40 they went eight and two their
last ten
and then the dodgers went nine and one
their last ten they're 79 and 34.
i don't know what do you think that's a
tough one i feel like the yankees
despite the last few years i still feel
like
push comes to shove
they have the history and i feel like
they step up i feel like the dodgers
always [ __ ]
choke the astros i don't know
you know if they don't have a trash can
can they do something and then you got
the mets they always [ __ ] the bed
but the cardinals are in first place and
i feel like they always do well
i'm just talking historically it just
seems like that's what ends up bad look
at the braves brazers 70 and 46
defending champions
maybe they sneak in maybe that's what
they do
i don't know
but i can tell you what i do know is
we're not red sox are not making the
playoffs all right diaper population
uh
let's see
any chance you could tell bill that
japan sells more adult diapers
than baby diapers
i really got a kick out of yesterday's
episode talking about the
underpopulation musk stuff
yeah but
the
elon musk [ __ ] i was talking about that
he was sitting there saying how people
are having less babies and that that's
how we were going to go extinct like
if we were in danger of becoming extinct
people would start go back to having 10
babies again
the fact that he would just suggest that
we'd be like well i guess i guess we're
gonna go extinct
is was the dumbest [ __ ] theory
i've ever heard in my life and i just
thought it was a classic example of a
guy who's considered smart just trying
to be interesting with his own [ __ ]
offbeat take i don't buy it on any level
as far as japan goes they live on a
[ __ ] island they've run out of space
right
they got all kinds of problems over
there i get it
i get it they're more adult diapers than
baby diapers well i don't know i don't
know what
i don't know what that proves
um
we just went through a [ __ ] pandemic
and we were still out [ __ ] that as
much as it
was killing all of those people the
world population still increased so i i
don't know what to tell you but hey i'm
not elon musk
all right
i'm not um
neil degrasse tyson this is my thing
about those guys i want to see those
guys
talking to other science
other scientists
and blowing
other scientists minds
i'm sick of these guys
just to do a recap the musks
the the the the tyson fury guy whatever
neil degrasse tyson guy
i'm so [ __ ] sick of them talking to
[ __ ] like me
i mean it's a layup that you're gonna
blow my mind
how does the moon affect the tides
dude think about that somebody figured
that out i mean that's who he's talking
to with me is it that hard to come off
as intelligent
um all right population studies
bill on the topic of population
um elon's reasoning might have been too
pedestrian i have actually written to
you on the topic in the in the past
uh the population is not growing at a
healthy rate it's virtually a unanimous
opinion among those
who study it for a living
i have never come across any scientific
or economic paper that agrees
there are too many people
how is that possible
i've come across [ __ ] that i've looked
up that was saying like once you go past
three and a half billion people the
planet can't sustain it
as far as like our ability to live here
indefinitely on the topic of the planet
the amount of waste we produce is not
proportional to the population directly
different societies produce different
amounts of waste
when all of this is considered it does
not change the outcome of the scientific
opinion on population
okay i was with you to that last
sentence
um what this sounds to me is people
moving numbers around
so they don't have to [ __ ] deal with
like
you're just gonna be a contrarian
well you know
there's way more people in india but
america has like 50 times the [ __ ]
waste
okay
so a billion people you know [ __ ] in a
river isn't bad too like there's too
many [ __ ] people i don't care
how you slice it
okay
rainforest is getting chopped down
species are going extinct the ocean is
fished out i don't give a [ __ ]
how you slice it there's too many
[ __ ] people
there just is and you're not gonna
move some [ __ ] around
with the numbers but you know i'm open
to it you convinced me that there's not
too many [ __ ] people
um i know i'm just pedestrian
um
all right
but i think like the the elon musk thing
saying like this you know there's more
old people than younger people and that
younger people are not having as many
kids and that's that's how we're gonna
go extinct is [ __ ] ridiculous
um i think that we would notice like hey
man there's only like a hundred of us
left maybe we should start having more
babies
you know
i think that that would probably happen
way before you got down to 100 people i
don't [ __ ] know all right owning a
scale
owning
a scale uh hey bill
there is all
uh pretty obvious stuff here
uh this is all pretty obvious stuff here
well i'm not the brightest guy
i heard you talking on anything better
about how paul should own a scale anyone
who doesn't own a s scaled
and isn't in perfect shape is a [ __ ]
i'm a former fat [ __ ] who is in denial
about my fat fuckness first thing i did
to change my situation was to get a
scale can you please send paul a scale
so we can monitor the results he's not
going to do it
he's not going to do it
i can just tell you that right now he's
not going to do it
um
you know
i don't know how to put it
it's just like
i walk around all the time going i'm a
fat [ __ ] and my wife goes you're fine
you're fine you look fine you have body
dysmorphia it's like no i don't
i don't i'm in i'm [ __ ] informed i'm
[ __ ] informed
like
how much
and i've been walking around with you
know an extra 10 pounds for like almost
two years now
um i've just been so [ __ ] busy i
can't get
over to the gym as much as i need to and
i i just need to get to the [ __ ] gym
that's how i stay in shape and just an
extra five pounds walking around on that
like how much that shortens your life
because each pound of fat is like
something like some crazy amount of like
five miles of capillaries that you gotta
grow to keep that part of your body you
know the new
additional skin and fat and all that
alive and that's
every heartbeat
your heart has to go an extra five
[ __ ] miles
um
you know there's people that are like uh
you know it's like that dad who wanted
to fight me last week like he thought he
was like a [ __ ] husky tough guy he's
like dude you're a fat [ __ ]
when he was going like what are you like
a buck 80 i weighed 180
in high school it's like yeah dude you
should probably only weigh 185.
but now you'll dude he looked like he
was every bit at 230.
100 [ __ ] obese 30 pounds overweight
is you know since you know obviously if
you're [ __ ] eight feet tall maybe
you're not obese but 30 pounds
overweight you're [ __ ] obese
and this guy was like twice that
but he's walking around you know
one of those guys that still eats
[ __ ] [ __ ] food but you know also
still does push-ups
so he thinks he's like in shape and uh i
think
you can have reverse body dysmorphia
where you can be a fat [ __ ]
and not think that you're a fat [ __ ]
and i think there's a lot of people
doing that
there's a lot of people out there just
buying bigger clothes
and uh
you know they do that thing
that thing where they just sort of bring
their hand down the front of their torso
i'm not that bad not that bad it's like
dude you're a [ __ ]
house
you're a house
um
i'm like 10 15 pounds overweight and i
have i already have difficulty with like
you know
taking my shoes off and stuff like that
like i'm not like i'm breathing hard but
i i just my stomach gets in the [ __ ]
way
not enjoying that at all
so um
that is like my big thing when i finally
finished editing this movie and was so
goddamn close
[Music]
um i'm going to uh get myself in shape
get on the other side of fenway the
other side of this movie and i'm just
hitting the elliptical every [ __ ] day
and eat well and uh
i should be fine
that's my big thing
um and i should get on the scale i
haven't got on the scale because i
already know what the [ __ ] it's gonna
say
all right um
farmland
frenzy
uh dear billy all the live long day
all the live long day what is that i've
been working on the railroad oh is there
a guy named billy in that song oh don't
live long damn
don't you hear the whistle
yeah dinah won't you blow your horn
i don't know um all right
all right you're right about the food
supply my sister is an art
agricultural scientist
she's been into the earth man for a long
time she doesn't listen to the podcast
so i couldn't get her to write in about
her story so here's an abbreviated
version
she wanted to save the earth
her whole life parentheses dork
started getting into clean food
initiatives that funded research on
what's going on with our foods this
brought her into the world of cancer
research which has a strong correlation
cause cancer rates just keep going up
and we've got cancers that now occur
1 000 of
per
cents more than they used to
yeah this is pretty loosely written
which then brought her to fighting the
corporate global takeover of the food
supply by supplying independent farmers
with legal help and anything else she
can provide them through raising money
this is what people should be doing
instead of focusing on dumb [ __ ] like
the color of ties or jokes that
comedians are telling should probably
try to protect the food supply
um all of this has sent her down rabbit
holes she never knew existed rich people
are buying up farmland and now
governments are making huge restrictions
on farmers that will knowingly destroy
their production and make it harder for
areas of the world to get food news
never covers these protests
the restrictions are unreasonable and
not planet-saving measures by any means
this all takes a toll on her and i try
not to say i told you
i told you say i told you so i think
because i would always tell her that the
illuminati is real and there are whole
cities underground
populated with different species of
aliens that work without government
jesus christ dude
that was you were driving right down
[ __ ] main street and all of a sudden
you went to the cornfields there in the
end you think that there's underground
cities with species of aliens that work
without the government
now let me ask how the [ __ ] do you know
that all right now i got to look this up
see what you guys do to me here
all right under underground
cities
populated
by
aliens
all right
darren cuyu underground city
is an underground city
in an ancient multi-level underground
city what
that's in turkey
the alien underground half a mile below
the surface in a cave too hot to explore
without an ice pack suit
what
underground alien bases flying saucers
come from inside
all right i think this is this is more
what you were talking about
underground alien bases flying saucers
come from inside the earth
exclamation point
an intelligent
agent's shocking report
flying saucers come from inside the
earth proof positive aliens have
established underground bases around the
planet
ancient tunnel system has existed on
earth since the time of atlantis
three entranceways can be found in many
major cities
what get the f all right now let me see
underground
city
entrance
guide to the underground
well this is in montreal because it's
freezing out
all right
illuminati
how many watch lissa inside the
underground city below
d.i.a what is dia
he shouldn't have gone down the
illuminati
underground manchester graveyard
entrance finally uncovered
finally
this is a youtube video oh listen to the
music
[Applause]
[Music]
all right here's a safe thing to assume
okay that if there's a tv show about the
illuminati there's going to be no good
information
or a video
i mean what what are we doing here
but that is disturbing what they're
doing with the farmland dude what the
[ __ ] is wrong are we gonna buy up all
the farmland and then what
destroy their production and make it
hard so what you can drive the price of
food up
i just don't understand like the level
of [ __ ] evil that's out there
all right
overrated underrated underrated getting
dumped
oh
getting dumped is definitely underrated
you know why because you have the broken
heart so you don't have to deal with the
guilt
and then you know once you kind of get
through it after a couple months you're
like wait a minute i'm single
this is [ __ ] awesome um this guy says
or this woman says i was bummed out for
about three months when my ex dumped me
i thought we were in love and happy and
on our way but after some time i was
thinking okay yeah
i can see what she's saying
now i'm single and i do [ __ ] i want to
do every day that i made excuses for
when we were together i love that she
dumped me now
and didn't try and do it later
that's amazing and i'll tell you the
best thing that you could do for
yourself and your happiness is do not
let your ex know that you are excited
that she dumped you
you know now it's three months have gone
by
you know
it's very it's a very weird thing when
you run into an ex-girlfriend
you know you got to be cool but you
can't be happy
you know what i mean
and they just see it like what's going
on with you there's something different
about you
like what what is it you're just like
what you're just happy
wow that makes me feel insecure like it
was my fault so now i'm gonna mind [ __ ]
you
and get you all messed up again so i'm
gonna be like yes
um underrated threesomes
those things are they're underrated
i just had one and it was awesome i've
heard people say man that's too much
work or you wouldn't know what to do
[ __ ] that i promise that every man or
woman knows exactly what to do i had no
training and everything worked out just
fine well good for you
congratulations
um why would someone say man that's too
much work man that's too much work like
they're turning down threesomes
somebody says that threesome is too much
[ __ ] work
well i actually also said that they
never had one but i would say this i
remember uh
axel rose a long time ago
i think talking to howard stern
was asked was talking about threesomes
he goes yeah you know somebody always
ends up feeling left out
and i'm sure he adds i don't
i don't [ __ ] hey man
i don't [ __ ] know so anyway
that's basically the podcast here people
i know i only did like 50 minutes or
whatever
but i am on vacation man
and i got to go play with my kids
and i'm getting ready for uh getting
ready for sunday i'm just sitting here
like
on pins and needles and then the next
moment it's like it's not even happening
so uh i knew this was gonna happen
because for months people going are you
stressing out about this gig i'm like no
i'm not even thinking about it i'm just
working on my act i'm pretending like
it's not even happening
so
i think i'll have one little minor freak
out
i'll get past that and then i go up
sunday and it's going to be [ __ ]
awesome
and
uh and when that show's over
that's when my vacation begins i'm
telling you that right [ __ ] now all
right i don't mean that in a bad way i'm
obviously gonna have a great [ __ ]
time but uh
it is what it is right um and with that
i'm gonna go play with my kids
um
is that it was there anything else i had
to promote i got toronto coming up i got
buffalo coming up someplace in
pennsylvania
um
and then maybe maryland
i have no idea but all you know is
football's coming up
[Music]
pat's looks [ __ ] great i mean i know
it's just a preseason game but i i liked
how our defense was looking
and uh
i'm just [ __ ] psyched i can't wait
for college football the whole thing
it's gonna be great
uh-oh here come the kids all right have
a great couple days i'll check in and
i'll check in on you uh check in on you
on thursday